durante la noche y el día los combates
continúan en nagorno karabaj los
intensos enfrentamientos entre los
separatistas apoyados por armenia y los
azerbaiyanos han provocado docenas de
muertes incluyendo a varios civiles sin
poder establecer un balance preciso la
noche del martes el consejo de seguridad
de la onu se reunió en una sesión de
emergencia en una declaración unánime
los 15 miembros pidieron el cese
inmediato de los combates el consejo de
seguridad expresa su apoyo al
llamamiento del secretario general a
ambas partes para que pongan fin a los
combates de inmediato calmen las
tensiones y reanuden sin demora las
negociaciones constructivas rusia está
tratando de activarse en el frente
diplomático el presidente ruso habló esa
misma noche con nicole para chillán el
primer ministro de armenia pidiendo un
alto el fuego moscú también está
tratando de contener a turquía un aliado
de azerbaiyán armenia descartó una
intervención rusa o internacional para
negociar con huacuz alegando que no hay
una atmósfera adecuada de requisito para
las conversaciones
patxi mian también dijo estar preparado
para una intervención militar en ankara
me acusa del derribo de uno de sus
aviones militares y armenia armenia y
los armenios de nagorno karabaj están
ahora tras el accidente del caza f-16
expuestos a una amenaza directa de
turquía
panahi según nuestros datos turquía
busca un pretexto para intervenir aún
más en este conflicto
generalitat conflicto
acusaciones refutadas por turquía pero
también por azerbaiyán turquía nos
ofrece apoyo moral pero turquía no
participa de ninguna otra manera
en todo el mundo la ansiedad está
creciendo parís berlín y washington han
pedido sin éxito un cese de las
hostilidades inmediato